first of all i would like to say how
we sadly feel the whole nation
deals and our friendship and our support
to the families of all the victims that
perished at sea
these men and these women
ran away from their country
and they wanted to get to the british
coast they ran away from their country
because
they were undergoing misery political
oppression
the absence of freedom
and they were victims
of the worst of systems which is that of
traffickers
and i think that that's what's
functioning in fact on the european
ground
so i would just like to express my
solidarity and compassion french people
but i'd also like to say very clearly
law and order forces are mobilized day
and night not yesterday or the day
before you say right from the beginning
there are the borders and france has
never had as many police officers and as
many chandam and as many military who
are mobilized to try to fight against
illegal immigration at the uh spanish
italian belgium borders as well and we
carry on doing so and uh our
mobilization is total as far as our
coasts are concerned
yesterday a thousand departures or
attempts to
depart two sides were avoided and since
january 7
800 were rescued
so these men and these women when they
arrive on the coast then it's already
too late so therefore this morning
the prime minister had a meeting
with
conclusions and the conclusions in fact
will be presented but of course we're
going to maintain this maximum presence
we're also going to carry on using
drones
especially the army ones we're going to
mobilize reserves have an extra
for extra help from the british because
all these men and these women don't want
to stay in france we uh
tell them that they're obviously able to
do so and there are centers in galilee
and dan kirk where they can go but we're
going to reinforce in fact
saving them at sea but
basically in a far stronger and
we've got we've got to develop things in
a far stronger way we've got to
reinforce cooperation cooperation
belgium holland germany but also
britain and the commission so that's the
decision that's been made but the series
of meetings will be take place with the
home office minister in the next hour
and the next days
in fact more than people that arrive on
the french ground coming from the south
as well as from the north and from the
east
but we want to better integrate also the
british to prevent these flows
by dismantling the uh networks of
we've done so in the last few weeks and
i really salute
but we really must ensure a stronger
european corporation i've always said so
from is a transit country
and we fight against these networks of
criminals
who use this stress
but we've got to improve european
cooperation and in fact the visits of
the prime minister and ministers at the
beginning of the week in belgium meant
that we were able to progress for sure
and we're now going to make sure that
those aspects are put into operation
with the countries that i've mentioned
going to reinforce